okay guys before the video starts I came
across the very video myself when ISA
passed away and I came across this vile
disgusting tweet from this Fatima a
salafiyyah Salam aleikum Baba that
brother ISA who died was he a Salafi and
this guy at the bottom who's the
bodyguard of the guy were going to react
to in the video
yeah it's a bodyguard for their quote
says can't confirm or deny Allah knows
best
these guys know very well his stance but
because my love mercy and improv are
left them look at the attitude when I
see the sisters message by the way I'm
not gonna I'm not saying she's a beliefs
it reminds me of a Blee saying - like
saying hi do you know Adam Allison I'm
Adam was he created of fire Oh was he
created of clay oh he was not crazy to
fire okay that arrogance is unbelievable
and guess what guys
it gets worse watch the video and see
how they backed by Bhave song but you do
not leave a dead man a dead man oh no
the guy is dead bun
leave him alone at least leave him alone
please
but my budget is however this exceptions
watching exposes some equality
I said ah Monique from whatever tre
better care to brothers and sisters and
their friends hope you guys it wouldn't
Charla I've been I was told of this
video and when I was told us of this
video if I'm not mistaken he says body
was most likely in the mortuary or on
his way to the mortuary what we do know
is that he wasn't buried what is very
clear is when I was told about this
video that was some kind of a live video
of this person which belongs to a coal
I'm personally not going it's not I
don't find within myself to call names
like they do to others insult shout mock
whatever yeah I'm not the type because
first is Ramadan number two the last
person I would ever want to give my good
deeds to be this person the last person
on earth so some people who were enraged
and upset with his father he's a Muslim
Bravo sadly with this brother they
insult swear shout etc etc Brava I
believe there's no point because you've
given him you cooked eats and that's the
last thing you should do to somebody
that you genuinely hate on the day of
judgment imagine you're going to give
your Buddhist is somebody that you
dislike just the way this guy this guy
cuz I'm sure I'm finding very hard to
call this is my problem this number this
I'm gonna miss this guy this guy who's
literally when you start out knots not
backbite what is the process of them say
it's as if you're eating the dead flesh
of your brother the dead flesh
subhanallah subhanallah bother eases
that mail have mercy on you you're alive
a new eating his flesh you're alive you
eating his flesh the time did you and
the gut virtually dead he's passed away
watch this video guys I just wanna watch
this video and I want to make it clear
for you guys because a lot of people
have a personal problem
never
I've never personal probably never a
personal problem but just know what this
kind of Kurdish behavior consist of
because it showed its true colors
finally it was there you've seen it
attack against me he jabbed the rest of
the people everybody you name it
everyone's finished luck and their eyes
they all misguided except the same sect
this is a tornado in Paris let's watch
the video for ourselves please unless
judge
they only mind for those who do not know
prophet ISA prophet is a passed away an
amazing amazing amazing individual we
must be good about him till the day we
die we will speak with a bomb in front
of Allah who will speak good about him
in front of the angels who speak Buddha
by him in front of the muslimeen will
spin good about him because it's not a
lie it is the hawk yeah that's the
center is now this is a video that was
done while Brahma is as body was in the
mortuary probably just turning cold
gradually did they wait no no no no no I
had to wait till we rest buried him put
him to rest - then do this video and I
blurred his face because I do not want
to look at his face why I'm this voice I
would love to change his robot just so
you guys hit clearly there's no
institution to speak the truth yeah
don't forget they are the bearers of
truth and they deceive don't forget guys
when they say the following is always
gonna fall over the pot and when they
stop yes he was you know this ok let's
see what's gonna happen carefully listen
carefully
he has many mistakes
when I died I wouldn't have mistakes
when you died you would have have
mistakes when Muhammad hijab dies he
would have had mistakes when move DeMint
dies you will have mistakes when Zach
might die he will have mistakes to
clarify that if it was something where
you say you know what this person is
gone into absolute misguided in the
context of he was saying worship graves
you should go and worship graves you
should commit innovation in the religion
you should go and do this you should go
and do that you should go on this till
you see you know what understandable
wait for the guy to rest maybe later
yeah understandable nobody's telling you
to praise yeah nobody's cometh in praise
because that is a phone on your neck you
do because may Allah have mercy on
prophet ISA amazing person beautiful so
you left your crowd and there's a video
an unseen video going to be released on
Salaam channel a interview with the wood
and ISA may Allah bless you and you're
gonna see you can even find some and
it's gonna be advice to the youngsters
and the youth look what he says never
this is something I have seen nothing
but this impact but by this individual
and his likes him specifically you think
that he's a prophet who says and he
always says this about me they used to
try to recruit me it was nice to me
except they were nice to me until they
really didn't work and when I was
helping him out against the Christian in
the park that's when he refuted me when
I was trying to help him as a brother
yeah as a prophet and awful and they
they instantly came confronted me
afterwards etc one of them tried to get
physically to the camera yeah I wish he
tried to get physical and and they have
hit believers they physically attacked
believers before he goes advisor do you
think you are who do you think you were
to say you know if advising many times
do you think you are
what why is unbeliev are you a perfect
Obama I've advised him the hell
do you think you armor well why don't
you think you are
that's advising they didn't listen
advice I literally didn't listen I've
been advised of memory job I didn't
listen I'm gonna advise him this guy
didn't listen I've been advising you
didn't listen hamdulillah Oh why's the
one that's judging him Allah will have
mercy on him and hamdulillah or what I
thank Allah but you guys are our judges
you would have thought all of us to the
fire and handle if not all rights gonna
judge us and Esau not oppressive values
like you but you do not leave a dead man
a dead man alone the guy is dead spun
leave him alone
at least leave him alone please I'm
begging this from a double line I'm not
gonna call you the name I'm not gonna do
that
I have a right to be angry the Prophet
peace be upon him when a Jewish man died
a Jewish man yeah and vocal were vocal
about the falsehood yeah they're only
the children of Israel he stood up out
of respect for the dead body the Prophet
stood out of respect for the dead body a
Jewish man this is a believer now this
is a living being
this is a believer and you couldn't hold
your tongue to eat his flesh the
analytic dead man's flesh may have a
person beautiful person
well my hopes to me that he was a better
ambassador to Islam then you could ever
be and Muslims are non-muslims testify
to that you you if I was to take your
soul we wouldn't ask for forgiveness for
you may have mercy on you we would not
go and start saying sham
he was like this he was my dad who's
like that everyone has mistakes we will
make to offering hope submit our like if
you thought you would be happy you would
be happy you would rejoice
and good manners have mercy upon email I
forgive it
but without trying to find the true
people Chris Amana some people maybe
they do up to me I'm no one but no some
people he was a forgiving about you
start so this I listen to and watch some
of these videos these videos understand
that's true
basically his warning you guys against
his videos
can anybody show me a single video of
Issa where he crosses the lines in a
major way like you see here this is
human al-qaeda
show me one video of Prophet ISA
crossing the lines how do you think his
family Christian family would feel if
their bushings are thinking well you
know what's gonna outweigh your evil
actions but good actions that believe is
dead and raise funds for him the good
actions that believers did I did nothing
I just had a following and I put the
link there people that gave us a package
Aria people that give for his daughter
and his wife people are going to his
family inshaallah is we're watching us
we are genuinely sorry on behalf of the
muslim community we are so so so sorry
but if somebody's talking ill of a dead
man may Allah's mercy on him we appoint
to stand here and defend his honor we
are going to finish on and testify so
the day we die that is with a beautiful
woman but you could ever be he was a
beautiful soul you see nice miss
Creighton anyone that's misguided if
there's anyone was quote important that
post disease is people like you people
like you because for example bad bite so
now these realize okay I'm backbiting
and this what made you guys this coat
they do this they are good towards the
Muslim the main leader of this coat
praises Obama
praises David Cameron yeah the killers
of Muslims praises thank you very much
for a better I understand you can see on
screen the coat this guy the leader of
this cult very leader does this now that
he and the study is being backbiting he
understood it and it said Clara what
they do is they clarified okay now let's
tell you why we came back his and he's
he's just defined somebody is there was
somebody who's calling for misguided and
he he has to cause he's the safe sex
he's safe him in his friends yeah chalet
something like something loud or
something la if I'm saying this for the
safe of it if I'm saying this for
anything
if Esau if I had a boot on if I had a
sister wallahi billahi i'm fast until i
if i would not if I would if there was
anyone they said I want your sister my
sister if I was to choose anybody who
would I want to marry I wanted to marry
either Issa or prophet Dawood and I
thought many other friends but
specifically specifically specifically
yeah so those bombs I'm not mentioned I
would lovely any of my sister Francis
specifically Yanni I would want brother
Esau specifically brother easier to
marry my sister
I want my brother easy to marry my
sister my daughter well lie because we
know when I spoke to his father in law
he says you know what he said when I'm
giving [ __ ] she was I said as I say this
because that man treated my daughter
like a princess he treated it was not
once not once I had a discipline of Issa
not once this is father-in-law what my
aunt something I said that to me
he said to me not once how
when a man like that yeah and if
somebody came to me yeah I've definitely
been doing checks yeah you'll be the
last person I would ever ever ever want
me or my daughter or my sister never for
marriage never toxic person you are
toxic I'm not gonna call your name
you're toxic
you know what breaks my heart out of all
of this I've got a message from a friend
of Esau this was when he was back in
school or secondary school I can't name
apology and why why he broke my heart
you know what broke my heart he was
telling his friends Esau may love mercy
any man what a man what a man what a man
he was what a man he was we're going to
we're gonna praise Him do not over he
was a man that he used to certain family
members would not let him to pray he
would go to the garden to pray for dirt
when I heard this one that wanted to
break down can you imagine he was not
allowed to pray whatever reason we're
not been in the family they said whoever
he was he used to go to the garden to
pray for him this was a man who were
called to align his messenger this was a
man of the Sunnah a man of the Sunnah
and you're gonna come here and
backbiting and work in the let it go
we're gonna turn a blind eye the only
thing that we don't want to see is your
face yeah and from this day onwards if
you I used to give yourself I'm after
everything you did yeah and you can in
being raised in this I would not give
you Salaam until you publicly apologize
I'm never gonna give you Salam and I
hope the Muslims never do Salaam yeah
it's your right but you run the line of
another believer unnecessarily you back
bye to them your back bitten him you're
slandering him your spawn during him and
the video that's gonna come out of
serums I'm gonna make this very clear
from brother is his own mouth it's gonna
make this very clear now you know I just
want to finish off this yeah because my
next video is going to be about cosmic
skeptic and the whole hijab issue and
accusations has been front Wharton
brothers and sisters not all
attempt at a profit Esau Muhammad hijab
Mehmedi chose more perfect he's not
perfect he knows that I know that he
knows I'm not perfect we advised one
another sometimes just go over my mini
job Madonna bless him yet so go and take
the enemy's side over him and when
enemies totally wrong with just this
doesn't mean if he job is wrong and he's
not something wrong we're gonna walk
back up cosmic skipped it because Allah
said speak the truth even if it's cancer
so if a job is long we're gonna come and
say that it's up he's a believer no but
somebody close me skeptic conscripts who
insults the Prophet peace be upon him
insults him sister-in-law he mounted on
top oh I should have been loud yeah
since this our professor awesome
and you go in and you protect him over a
job and you couldn't wanna see what he
calls him let's see I just want to
finish on this cuz the next video is
gonna be about this very topic we're
gonna win detail about this look what he
says guys how many job is having issues
with cosmic scripted yeah
and because we see someone's insulted
Muslim women's they're in bags bags you
know inanimate objects but you put them
in bags no bus pin in the back yeah
Somali sisters they think you guys in
the back yeah okay you're in bags and he
says and it's insulting the Prophet look
what this guy this is the very same guy
who always just have to believe it's
always nobody says to the stand away
refers to cosmic skip together
sorry corner or line between the
gentlemen and plow should they choose to
take a six-year-old as a bride and to
mount and abuse them three years later
sorry for not not all right between the
this is an atheist and a gentleman
between the this is an atheist and
gentlemen gentlemen
you know if I went into Somalia and said
you shouldn't be putting women in bags
they'd probably say yes they would
atheist gentlemen
it cost me gentlemen but he doesn't see
my problem I have made a job somebody
who insults the Prophet is a gentleman
your brother who's defending the owner
of the the Prophet peace be upon him
he's not even the same brother hijab why
could he expose your coat
may Allah expose you guys more I'm gonna
leave that video about mechanical can
you don't go I'm gonna leave that we do
like that yeah I don't talking loner
my name's Rudy I'm gonna do is every
action we get the cosmic skeptics
allegations and accusations towards IRA
and the whole debate etc and we're gonna
go through all of that myself because
I'm trying to intervene between the two
there's no sin Bonin and I'm gonna just
I'm not gonna take your job said I'm
gonna be just probably job he was wrong
cosmic skeptic we're gonna talk about
certain issues is what if you're wrong
as well okay we're gonna do that rockin
the sisters you saw this you saw this
for what it really is so when we would
seem that these guys are closed no while
we're seeing that we don't just have
personal problems because these guys
believe that everyone's innovator
everyone in the prop the only Santa Fe
is him and another guy this made very
clear shame on you she needed public
repentance for biting your dead brother
eating his flesh shame on you shame on
you shame on you
and anybody that talks to this man
anybody that has videos do not record me
do not record any of the prophets do not
record us go on record him